what was the first quentin tarantino
movie that you watched
i think it was pulp fiction i think it
was
um but very close to the same time i
watched
um true romance and linked them
you know as the screenwriter or as
tarantino being the screenwriter and
um true romance really knocked me out
like pulp fiction obviously did for the
obvious
reasons that everybody else kind of
feels you know it was like this new
voice and
if you miss reservoir dogs and a lot of
people came to reservoir dogs through
pulp fiction
and i'm one of those but also true
romance
so those two together i was like wow mia
wallace
and alabama whirly like i was just yeah
i was knocked out by those gals
now what about kevin smith too if you're
growing up on the east coast
oh yeah that's kevin said okay so yeah
so so sort of this whole
like indie filmmaker movement right yeah
and link later falls into that too sure
yeah of course
and did you ever envision when you when
you saw those films that
one day you'd be interviewing all the
actors that he worked with
no it was nice
no i definitely wasn't thinking that way
then i was
i was a model actress
so i um limited myself
in that respect i think and i have
grown up into who i should be but yeah
no i definitely didn't think one day i'd
be sitting here
talking about quentin tarantino and
sitting with those fantastic people
what made you decide to make the film
and you had already done a film about
richard linklater
so i co-directed link later with michael
dunaway
and we so being
i spent a lot of time in austin so i was
familiar
with more familiar with rick and his
work because
he kind of runs that town you know
there's a lot of that i was an extra on
the newton boys
oh nice
so when i heard that michael dunaway was
doing this project
he was he was kind of looking for a
partner and i and i happened to be
at the right place at the right time
actually it was a kevin smith interview
that we met that he was doing for link
later
so that's how that happened it was very
organic and
amazing um and michael has moved on to
do other things and left me to do kind
of
you know move on with tarantino on my
own but
that's how that came to be it was it was
very natural
and easy and awesome
so when you saw how much fun and easy
the process was with the link later film
as a
being a co-director or writer on it
what made you think you know i want to
do this one and i want to do it on my
own
well i um i really
i've realized this as i've been talking
about why
i decided to move on to this because
it's not something i really thought
about
you know i just i was like oh i'm i love
this i'm doing this
but the part that i really love about it
was
finding out things
that are misunderstood you know and
either debunking
or digging deeper into so for example
with link later
what we learned as we were talking to
people and even around austin what i
would hear oh he's very laid back
and he's very easy going and as we did
these interviews
i was like he's not he's not laid back
in that sense
like he's very intense and knows exactly
what he wants to do and i found that
fascinating i was like wow
i was like this idea that people have
isn't who that person is
but let's show that let's like really
show
that side of it and how that affects the
filmography and where things come from
so to move into tarantino um
on my own i think i was
really driven by the misunderstanding of
his female characters
um and and what i would hear again about
quentin was that he was very um
he's very nice and clint's very nice and
when you see him
in interviews or the idea that we have
of quinn
nice wasn't the word that would normally
come to mind so i was like
what what is that you know what is that
where is that coming from
so digging into um we're not even
digging into allowing
people what i love about this
documentary the like not interviewing
the director and sitting with people and
his friends and colleagues and just
letting them go
and just discuss you're like oh that's
the real breath of quentin that's
what that is that's where it comes from
so and obviously we'll get
more into that but that was
for me really exciting and to be
involved with people that do
what they love to do and are really good
at doing like
that's attractive no matter what
industry right somebody's really good is
it like
um you know
watching the the fastest person on the
planet like you want to watch that race
like it's really
thrilling to see people do what they're
really good at and quentin's
a master of filmmaking so yeah i was
really excited to
to move on into it on my own in that way
i understand you've been a sales agent
for some time you have
wood entertainment yes okay at what
point did you
reach out to quentin and say you wanted
to make this movie how was it
and what was the day like when you got
the word
i remember how i felt i remember was on
the phone i think
i might have been in the car but it was
ling litter the link letter doc had just
come out i think
and i was ready to to move you know i
really wanted to
to dig into clinton um he was
i think he was still in production on
hateful eight
when we started because
so quinn wanted to see the link later
doc
he's like well who is this girl you know
so
i was like oh here's a link and they're
like no quinton doesn't watch links
so we had to wait for the dvd to be
printed
because you know and send him the dvd
while he was shooting
and he took time to watch it which is
amazing um
but like he just loves films and that's
just one of those things that
proves again how much he does like he'll
stop in the middle
of production and watch a film that's
pretty amazing
um so he watched it and gave us his
blessing he said he
you know he loved that it concentrates
on the filmography and
not being an expose you know like that
my interest is definitely not
what's you know the the juicy stuff that
people don't know about quentin
that's not exciting to me um
and obviously that showed in the link
later documentary which was great so he
he allowed us to keep going
or allowed us to move forward with with
his doc
but i remember getting the information
i was like oh cool so i can go
and there's probably a half hour later
where i was like
quinterantino watched my first piece
and liked it enough to say yes
like that i just got chills that was
that was very surreal i was and there's
there hasn't been another talk about him
and i doubt it's because
of lack of trying from other filmmakers
you know
so so the slow realization of what that
actually meant
like i still can't articulate i guess
it's pretty amazing feeling and how
special i i felt i guess i was like wow
cool i can do this he liked my first
film and ultimately when i met him
he you know how he quotes um
from movies like he knows everything
like everything stays in his head
so when i finally met him he quoted a
couple lines from
that link later doc oh wow i think i
almost fell off my chair i was like
oh my gosh yeah but he's just a lover of
film like
all of it all of it including my little
glitter doc
yes that's what i was wondering is when
you got that call or where whatever it
was a text
that were you almost like oh no now like
this is really happening like
that scary oh okay yeah i'd be totally
freaked out
that eventually came where i was like
this better be good you know like i
better do a good job i better hold this
carefully sure yeah
but that wasn't initial initial i was
like okay i'm just gonna do my thing
okay cool move forward and then yeah
that carried through the whole
documentary i would say that feeling
of of holding it carefully it you know
beca just because these people are
sharing really intimate
details about their special relationship
with this amazing
director and that was a lot that was a
lot to care for
you know so through the entire process
it was very much like how do i care for
this
visual person and what they're saying
and
and and pull out what's important to the
tarantino conversation as a filmmaker
and as a person right um
that that feeling never went away that
was a constant
like hold
of responsibility yeah there is there's
a trust factor
and then if you don't want to break it
because then
they may not want the interview out or
whatever and it is a lot of
responsibility even even doing these
it's just you know people are willing to
come and sit in front of yeah it's a lot
tell you yeah i don't think people
necessarily get
you definitely give a lot of care to
that which is
wonderful like i feel like i'm in good
cans when when i sit with
i want people to feel the same way you
know it's like it's okay and if you say
something you're like oops i shouldn't
have said that
i'm not going to go put that on the
screen right i think that's the big
thing that knowing that
you're not going to go and try to like
spin it because it'll get more
right of reaction so right
especially in this this landscape that
we're in yes currently
definitely and people look to
misconstrue and i think people are set
up to
misconstrue so that it does get more
attention
you know yeah if i'm understanding this
correctly then so quentin didn't want to
meet
with you until the film was finished oh
yeah
so part of that conversation with him
and giving his blessing
was that yeah he made it very clear that
he did not want to meet me
and i was like oh i was kind of crushed
maybe i thought i could use him as a
reference or
actually to check things with him to
make sure that i was doing things
correctly
and he's like no no no we'll meet
afterwards
um that's interesting and he's 100 right
of course of course because
he understands all aspects of filmmaking
including if he was part of it
it could be viewed as bias right
and it would have been especially after
the things that have come down
during making the film um so
he was he was absolutely right to not be
involved
thanks quinn
[Laughter]
yeah and you started filming the first
interview when what year was this
it was late 2015 okay
so different things have happened since
then
different news items um what was your
feeling on including some things or
maybe not
including some things in the film uh so
while we were making the film we were
almost we had a few more interviews to
go
um and the weinstein company approached
us
um to buy the film and ultimately we
ended up doing that deal
um mainly because i was like well this
guy has been quinton's partner through
all of his films
today you know from reservoir dogs
through at that time was hateful eight
um so it seemed to make sense and we
were gonna finish it together
um and then things
went terribly wrong um
you know obviously outside of anybody's
control except his
maybe um but i october 5th
right the new york times article dropped
um
and where were you that day sorry didn't
i i i was still laying in bed and i was
up and i was
going through the news and and i saw
that
and we were already a little bit at odds
just because of
them being who who they are and how they
do business
so it was very aggressive you know so we
were already kind of having a hard time
so when this happened
um and knowing the past and being a
woman
when this came to light i was like oh
yes oh no
my film like now what
so it it was a year-long battle
to get the film back and get the rights
back
and it was definitely
very difficult for the film and for the
for the nuts and bolts of that sure and
as a woman it was
it was really it was a really
um
it was very lonely because nobody wanted
to
help once that happened you know got
very quiet sure
so and i i feel that's true for women on
the personal side so
there was a lot of crossovers personally
and business-wise
where it was very like wow like the the
feelings that go along with
with that i know i'm being vague and i
kind of apologize for that but
it's understandable it's it was just it
was a very difficult dark
lonely year but
fighting for the film especially after
doing most of the interviews at that
time
and learning about quentin and learning
about him and how
he feels about social issues
and women in general um i was like i
have to fight for this film
like i have to or else it's just going
to fall
into the abyss i don't even know how
many other films are still caught up in
filmmakers
like it's not most of them have not
gotten their films back
so i fought very hard it was a very hard
battle
but ultimately we won so it's a great
story yay
and then we had to revisit how we're
going to
end the film because we had interviewed
with bob weinstein harvey was supposed
to be involved
harvey was always part of the
conversation because it was harvey and
quentin
we're talking about his filmography of
course you talk about harvey
and his participation in that harvey was
the one who took a chance on quentin
so that's very much a part of the story
and now that changed
right well now the story had to change
and quentin now is out
with regards to that right that
partnership was done so
we had to address it and i hope i i took
care of
it i tried to present it without
a side like this is what happened and
then we and then we move on
um so there was a lot of decisions from
what
started out as this amazing i got this
great project and everybody's supportive
and everybody's showing up you know sam
jackson shows up and he's like i called
quinn he said to show up
awesome you know to all of this
horrible stuff happening and now
but now we're back right so now now
we're up and we're going and we're going
to finish the film
and and and again now you're caring
you're like okay what do i do with this
right and you figure it out and it's
hopefully it's well done and it had been
in all the trades
that the weinstein company had picked up
the film correct
yes so it was everywhere yeah yeah right
okay
yeah it was a big deal it's a big deal
for p you know
because it was a tarantino dock and his
association with quinton
but then all these other filmmakers that
are caught up in the same
issue on the business side right
and then again the whole other
conversation which
overlaps for for quentin and
uma had issue rose mcgowan um
hit mayor cervino who you know was
clinton's girlfriend back
then um you know pieces of that had come
out
um it was it was crazy it was crazy
and as much as you try to separate it
it's very entwined
for everybody personally and
business-wise
and it set off basically this new me too
movement essentially of
many people coming forward and not just
women but men as well and and so
now thankfully yeah conversation um
are you okay with talking about because
you decided to pull the film from them
or
do you not if you don't want to talk
about it you don't have to no sure
um when you decided to
pull the film and look for a new
distributor
what was the reaction from people in the
industry
so okay so when i when i did get the
film back
there were definitely mixed responses
um when i went back into the marketplace
to find another distributor
ultimately i decided to partner with
entertainment squad
who shikhaed berenson who came from epic
epic pictures
we partnered and we're putting it out so
eventually i was like i'm done with
these conversations
because there was there was definitely a
lot of fear um especially since i
included the conv
the conversation um so
yeah so when i re-entered the
marketplace with it it was
it was very mixed uh some people were
like well why don't you pull that out
you know why don't you just not have
that conversation in the documentary
because what does that really have to do
with quentin's filmography
i had a really hard time being like oh
that totally makes sense
i should take that out it didn't it just
didn't make sense
so i was like i'm gonna
do what i feel is the truth sure um
and present that and we went a different
way with the distribution
which is really exciting so right it's
just interesting because i've known
a few other documentary filmmakers who
were in the
middle of a film and a scandal broke and
for them
not to put it in the film would just be
like it i mean i get not totally
focusing on it having it at the main
crux of the movie but it just wouldn't
work like they would be so severely
criticized for not
at least saying something right so so
then there's that
so you're damned if you're doing damned
if you don't so
i was like well here it is and you do
what you want with it that's how i feel
it comes across
in the documentary this is what happened
you know feel however you want about and
that's been very mixed too um the
reaction from women
obviously is wow that's really great
that that's in there
but then there's the next step i didn't
know quintin was such
a women's advocate you know i didn't
realize that his characters were
written from from this feeling
rather than what he's accused of or
being abusive with his actresses or his
characters or what have you
so i i hope that
women revisit quinn's filmography
with a different eye i i know
well i always i was always there i think
but you know a lot of women have been
turned off by
you know the blood and the violence and
this and that but if you
again with all of that stuff when you
understand where all of that is coming
from with quentin
he he's it's not as sam jackson says to
scratch his nails on the blackboard
he doesn't do that it all comes from a
very
it's a much deeper place and i think
women should revisit
i think they'll really dig some of these
characters i mean um
uma's character and kill bill um
whichever
the bride beatrix whichever name you
want to choose to call her but the bride
story is amazing you know she was
she was raped her child was taken from
her she's got all these issues going on
and she's like i'm going to get rid of
those people
so he takes it to an extreme but he
takes that emotion to an extreme
and it's really it's a great ride but
it's much more meaningful
it shouldn't be written off women need
to revisit
and really look at them any advice for
filmmakers who are in the middle of a
film or even at the tail end of one
filming whatever editing and something
newsworthy happens and they're
choice and how they're going to be
criticized either either way
um i wrestled
for months with it like literally sat
down
and stopped editing i was like what am i
gonna do with this
um and i and i went back and forth
because you have your own opinions
and wait my advice would be to wait
until you realize that you're not
inputting your opinion and you're just
presenting
and it should be included possibly i
mean it's obviously case by case but if
it's something that's
uh like in this case that that's so
important to that story
and that and quentin's filmography
here specifically it does apply to
include it
but i had to wait until it was
clear right so
i i didn't want to present my opinion
of it that would have been a very
different documentary
and would have skewed it so as a
documentarian
you you really have to make sure that
your mindset has settled and you're
delivering it
as it is yeah one of the filmmakers that
i
would talk to that encountered a very
big scandal and was in the middle of
their film they used headlines
to show because i mean they they
couldn't not
i used headlines actually yeah okay and
that that was a way to just show
that this was not that was it was not
your opinion it was what was out there
exactly yeah and then you have to be
careful which headlines
you choose too you know the wit the way
they're written
are you are you throwing this in
people's faces or
are you you know make sure it's
again this is just me i want to make
sure that it was
when somebody said something and that's
the headline that's what they said
right now i guess i'm jumping into uh
fake news out there
yeah be careful not to pick the fake
news um
but i guess that's true you know
that's tough that's really it was really
hard
that was a very very difficult decision
and then
making the decision how do you tell it
right i chose not to have
it's like a voiceover like it's all the
actors speaking
there's no voiceover in the in the film
so we chose michael madsen's
telling of what happened to go over that
montage
right and we used footage that we've
seen before
from quintin's films under it
so that you're you're looking at the
same thing differently
right so with regards to that story
specifically again with harvey quinn
well this was going on at the same time
that these were going on
guitar
so then there's that then there's the
device you used to tell the story
what were the first steps to making this
film well the first steps to making
a documentary about somebody else that
they're not going to be in by the way
that they're not right there's a um
deciding not to interview the director
is interesting because it's like when
you
meet someone here like oh i might want
to date that person or
i'm not wanting to get i might want to
get into business with that person
like what do you do you ask about them
right you ask friends you ask colleagues
you cut and there's kind of an innocence
to to the way that comes out
you know um
not knowing somebody and trying to find
out right it's like that
so i really liked i really like that
angle um
i'm a little off though so um with your
question
uh so did he have he supplied
with with whom to contact or are you no
oh okay no no no he was v so queen was
very
hands off he said yes you have my
blessing
if people call me i'll tell them that i
support it
like that was as far as he was going to
go that was it um
and they you know i don't know if
everybody called it didn't come up all
the time
but every now and then it did you know
some of you'd be like oh yeah i called
him
oh you know so i knew it was happening
um
but he no there was no list there was no
you should talk to these people
now when i did sit and talk you know
with um
for example eli roth he's like you have
to talk to scotty spiegel
like scotty spiegel was not on my radar
right
and scotty ends up being like he is so
funny
he's so funny he brought so much life to
the documentary and great stories and
great insight and they have a long
history together
so we found out that way like who we
should talk to
or who yeah so it was very um
it felt very pally you know it was
really nice
it was really nice and would you meet
these people at their office their home
like how
did you have a designated spot to do the
interview we did have a spot
um some people didn't want to go to
santa monica
or some didn't want to leave their home
they'd prefer to do it at their home
some people definitely were like no i
don't want anybody in my home i'm going
to come to you
so it was whatever worked for them we
that's what we did
and we made it as easy as possible
would you give them the questions
beforehand
yes if they asked for it some did some
didn't
it was it was real it was very relaxed
it was it was very however you wanted to
do this that's how we'll do it
whatever you want me to not touch on we
won't touch on that
um nobody ever shut anything down
actually
that's that hasn't come up as i've been
talking about this yeah that was really
interesting
there was no i'm definitely not talking
about this ah there is
there is one thing i hope you don't ask
me anything about his foot fetish
ah i've seen that in the comments
definitely come up in the comments
yes i think somebody was very upset that
we didn't mention his foot fetish but
if they didn't talk about it well you
know
if they didn't bring that up i wasn't
going to sure
you know i don't think that necessarily
applies to his from
filmography except
he does have great shots of women's feet
i have to say okay and once if i have
using once upon a time in hollywood yet
we have yeah that's great so with um
[Music]
with quali is that her name yes uh-huh
what's her first quality margaret
quality
mcdonald's when she say yeah when she's
smashing her feet up against the
windshield
and he's adorable that is right to her
character
too and and the awkwardness of the
driving and you know they're on the
the road or whatever yeah that's true
that is good actually mia wallace when
she comes out in her little black capris
and he shoots from her feet when she
walks in she's about to
turn on the the recorder
it's right before she overdoses oh but
it's just a shot of her feet
interesting how she walks in and kind of
smashes her feet into the carpet
it's pretty cool for a fetish that's
yeah it works for him right it's tasty
that's pg pg
with your film on richard linklater did
you include him in the movie
no you didn't okay so this is the second
film those yeah
that's def from the beginning that has
been
how i wanted to present these
interesting
and why why do you think that works um
to not have the artist that is is it too
much it's going to be too biased
then to have i think i think it's just a
different take there's plenty of
documentaries that
that do and we say and we listen quinn
actually
said you know how boring to listen to
somebody else talk about themselves
i didn't feel that necessarily you know
because i i love to listen to people
talk about
their their filmography or their life or
whatever you know it's
it's fascinating but for there's plenty
of documentaries that
that do that this i wanted to really be
just fresh and fun and
again it's it's like innocence it's very
open
you know it's it's opinions it's
experiences
and and you learn through those
right if somebody came in and said yeah
but this is me
and it pulls the direction and it
pulls it differently so now you're like
oh then we just have to listen to you
and you're the final word right you
don't get all those
i wouldn't be able to sit and tell you
how i am or who i am and why
necessarily but i bet my husband could
you know in a different way sure or my
mom or my sister
or colleagues or you know it's just a
very different
softer approach i think what are your
thoughts on when an artist's work
stops being about the work and it's now
about the artist i mean
because now people it seems like when
you get to the level of a quentin
tarantino
link later whomever it's no longer like
wow this is a great film it's oh it's
their film
so now you're gonna judge it through the
previous films or any news or whatever
and now they're under a new set of
criteria that no longer has to do with
the story
that's interesting i think
some
[Music]
i think some people directors might
be skewed that way and i guess it
depends on which angle you're coming
from like
do you see their stamp because you know
it's their movie because they have
a certain style what have you that's who
they are
right so you're gonna see that the other
side i guess would be placating into
that
um right is that kind of where you're
asking like when does it be
when do they shift or when do we shift
as an audience
that's a good question actually that's a
good question to my question because i
was thinking it's more
about the the they're up against critics
they're up against people that love
their work
and they're up against attractors which
is going to definitely come at that
level
whether it's valid or not you know
especially in the film world
there's a lot of people that are vying
for these certain spots and because
there's so few of them
it lends itself to a lot of like trying
to take people down
you know a couple notches you know i i
could speak to it this way i think
um i think as a filmmaker you have to
consider your audience
right and there's
and then there's a responsibility in
that like what do they
expect and where does that meet
your art right
and i'm sure that's a very difficult
balance
for for directors or anybody
at that level i i think quentin very
much
respects his audience and loves his
audience he's a fan
himself so if he's watching
a bruce lee film i suspect that he wants
to see
certain things from him right
because of his love for him so
i i would hope that they relish in that
without succumbing to their own press
right sure and the audience you know we
have a
we've got a tough crowd with the
audience they could be rather fickle
yeah and they can have their own reasons
for being fickle you know
we've seen different directors that have
had one hit after another and then
unfortunately something doesn't take and
then
it's just like a feeding frenzy and it's
not warranted in my opinion but
and then there's the the whole thing of
movie critics and
are those critics actually filmmakers or
are they
connoisseurs of cinema but they've never
actually done it
right and so who's you know anyway
that's another conversation but i was
just curious because at that level
it's so much i mean he's become you know
just the same as kevin smith or whoever
it's it's about oh well this is a kevin
smith film or this is a quentin taranti
it's not like the people don't see it
with eyes of just this is just a film
wow i really like the story i've heard
that about uh once upon a time in
hollywood a little bit
because he really just goes and
after doing this documentary and
watching that
like i'll go back to why i wanted to do
the documentary to begin with like
watching people
do what they're really good at what they
love is amazing and i
see that all over that film he loves los
angeles
and you see the love for los angeles in
the film right
you know he loves the what if scenario
you definitely see that you know um
so it's a great film and it stands on
its
own without having a tarantino knowledge
before right so beautiful film um
i think that's why he also says i'm only
doing 10.
i think he's cutting off again because i
think he's brilliant with regard to all
aspects of filmmaking including this
he doesn't want to be the old man
director he doesn't want to be uh i
think eli roth digs into this a little
bit
you know he's a and tim roth actually uh
they like he's only doing 10. he wants
to stay fresh he wants to say you know
and
maybe that's maybe that's part of the
reason maybe
like he doesn't want to be judged that
at that point
or he doesn't want to make those
mistakes
i don't know it's interesting to think
about though
right but he's definitely stopping he's
definitely you know he's
and how fascinating is that and this
isn't like one of these farewell tours
where like someone says yeah
this is the last one he doesn't seem
like the kind of guy to mince words you
know he's
very he he kind of sticks to his his
he has his idea of something and he
executes it and
that's how he feels i i don't think he's
changed much
uh in that way you know he's
he's never apologized for oh you oh
was it too much violence for you did i
say the n-word too much
did i hurt too many women did you know
there's no
he's like no it's a story that's where
it lives and he owns it
sure well it's like howard stern show if
you're going to tune in
you know what you're going to get you
know and it's it's it's not for children
and and
you're going to laugh at times and maybe
you'll be offended others but
you know what you're getting and so
don't watch it
don't listen if you don't want that i
don't know that's just my
opinion and yeah but uh but definitely
love to go in there and judge it though
well a quote i think from howard and i
think this is something that you had
told me david was that that his haters
watched his show more often or listened
to it
than the people that oh just to sit
there and be offended right i just want
to sit here and be offended over and
over again so i have something to
complain about
i've said this about east coasters
because i'm from there so don't judge
um you know coming out to for in texas
for a while and coming out to
california oh like you know what do east
coasters like to do like what's like the
past time whatever it's like complaining
complaining like they love it they love
it they love it
well if the weather's always cold yeah
you got to stay inside do something
which is ornery because of the snow
were there any interviews for the film
that you could not secure
so you there are definitely interviews
that um i wanted to be included
in this that didn't for whatever reason
uma definitely visited and tried to be a
part of it and forever
whatever reason i think we've seen
reasons as to
why we can make our own opinions there's
probably others
she ultimately declined um
but she's very present um
i laurence bender i i definitely would
have liked to include
as his longtime producing partner um
and i'm you know everybody has reasons
scheduling issues
with uh unfortunately john travolta i
believe that's what happened there
um and with dicaprio and pitt as well
uh but at the same time i mean i have a
list of people that i would have loved
to have in here um if
i guess thankfully i couldn't get
everybody i'd still be shooting
i won okay and how long would this
documentary be
so tarantino has a very
large community and very wide net and
there's
any part of him can be dug into
deeper i mean we mentioned the music how
he uses music
in the documentary we mention it
we we point to it but we didn't even
have time to talk about that and that's
huge that's huge or um i mean
there's so many parts of him that we
could have gone way deeper and that goes
with the people too
so we did we did the best we could but
lauren's bender i definitely would have
definitely would have
i think we miss him a little bit yeah
quentin did an interview where he said
he just really loves
when he looks at the film and he
realizes it's all like goes back to him
with the pen and paper
just kind of writing and started there
and then has become this big thing
how is this for you when you think about
these two documentaries with these two
legends filmmakers that you love
just started with you watching their
films being a film lover
what magic can you take from that little
statement that quinn's talking about
yeah i feel with these with these
documentaries
um now i'm working on a narrative
so that's that feels like oh
you know you have these moments like oh
i could see this character and i can see
this and i can see that
with the with the documentaries it's
it's so much more not me because they
tell the story
so i think my magic moments come from
what are they gonna say you know and
really
because they
i don't tell this story that they do
right so
you go in and you sit down you're like
how's this going to go
sure right and then you do that with i
think we had 15 or 16
interviewees on this so
it's very much like a what's going to
happen
what are they going to present so that
we can go back
and have fun with
quentin tarantino you know so it's very
off of me it it it comes
i see what you're saying right it's less
personal it's it's it's much less but
yeah
sure it's definitely not about what am i
going to do
right because they tell me that's how i
feel about this
like they they tell the stories that
again going back to richard linklater
what was amazing is to find out that
keanu reeves said it there
there's no slacker in this slacker right
he's all that far in the trailer
like it's great i'm like yeah like he's
he's not what
people think he is or there's more to
what people think he is
you know so that's really fun to unravel
and that's that's the magic for me and
with quentin
he's yes he's this big
huge personality but he's also really
intimate and brilliant and specific
you know so that was exciting
to come out and then the different ways
you they tell you that
and then how we bring that around to the
way he shoots something or
the the reason there's blood all the way
over there and not just right he
you know like what makes quentin
quinton and it's like weaving all that
together
so that's the magic for me if that
answers you
it does and sorry for going with that i
know it was sort of like wait is this a
real question what is this right here
that's cool though because that's it's
um
i think it's different i think it's
different that you know
a lot of people go out for a documentary
with an intent you know or very specific
you know the water is bad in flint right
so we're going to find out why and how
that affects people
so you're going this way i feel with
with this documentary comes the other
way it comes around
interesting right when you did your film
on richard linklater what
happened once the film was out how did
people especially in the austin area
react because he's sort of austin's
darling not sort of it he is
you know austin aside from robert
rodriguez
yeah i um when link leader came out
there was a lot of there were mixed
reviews
i think when you're a first-time
filmmaker
people are maybe a little bit harder
you know they don't know what to expect
it's kind of the opposite of what we
were just talking about right
so they don't know what to expect um
people are revisiting that film and i'm
getting a much different response
this time around because they kind of
understand now
why you know i got so much flack for not
interviewing the director
oh my god like as soon as they knew that
like that was it for them they're like
they're out
you don't interview the director it's
not the definitive
documentary interesting well what is the
definitive documentary on somebody in 90
minutes
you know like who what is that
and if it's not this that's okay but
this is what this is
so people are revisiting that and seeing
it differently which is really nice
it's um
it's interesting though because
yeah yeah i i think it could have um
done a lot better more people should
have seen that
it's fun on rick you mean yeah yeah yeah
and
so knowing that that that was something
that was said that
that that part that the subject quote
unquote actual subject of the
documentary is not in it
if you were mad at me about that i know
people were mad
like how could you not how is it a
documentary if you don't interview him
but what i find interesting interesting
is that we're doing a documentary on
somebody who's still alive and working
right i mean i just saw one on miles
davis and he wasn't in it
you know there might have been some old
footage exactly definitely
um but it was about the music and it was
about the people that knew him and some
of the troubles that he dealt with and
it was fascinating yeah so
yeah it's different it's different i
mean there's different ways of showing
things and if you're doing
only the person that it's on then it's
like
it's a mike wallace interview and you're
you know know nothing against martin
luther king
is great but yeah you know what i'm
saying yeah it's just very different um
was it francis four coppola that uh his
documentary just came out
is that the were it's him talking about
all his films oh i didn't know that no
i'm not aware of that
i'm not saying that one um
that's very interesting too there's
changes it's very different yeah there's
different styles
so uh you know there's verite there's
different
and there's including the person in it
and then there's not and
the story is going to be maybe somewhat
different i mean we all see ourselves
differently than other people
see us so and i find that fascinating
right why not have other people tell the
story
yeah what did studying quentin tarantino
teach you about storytelling
what did quentin teach me about
storytelling that
the
his his attention to detail on every
level
i i think that's what i think that's
what quinn taught me
like you have to pay attention to
everything
it's all important um the fact that he
has
the kangaroo from pulp fiction on the
shelf in jackie brown
and i believe in hateful eight those
little
those little things um not only is it
cool
but it's um
it's cool here you know you're like oh
because a kangaroo meant so much back
then um
in pulp fiction to br to bring it now
and gives the viewer something
to look for look forward to um
i mean that's his type of thing but uh
uh what's another example of of the
detail the um oh
like uh uma's shoes her little tiger
asics which i've got little white ones
on
um on the when she walks across the
glass
i think it says you on the bottom
of it or off one of the other
like little things like that that speaks
to her character
is amazing you don't notice as it floats
by maybe
but we still pick it up as humans
right our brain still maybe not the
you on the sneaker
specifically but the attention to detail
shows right um i should think of another
good example of that
but he's there's nothing
out of place in a tarantino script
or a tarantino film or even his
marketing
i mean he's a master pretty much across
all
aspects of filmmaking um and i think i
think that's what i learned about
what i hope to carry with me
is the attention to detail and then
there's also the part of quentin where
people want to hear him speak
he's his own same with like kevin smith
where like they're so fascinating to
listen to
they are fascinating and that's not true
with a lot of directors
but those two yes definitely quentin
like there's no
subject that he loves so much again when
you're listening to somebody
or watching somebody do what they love
to do or talk about something that they
love and they're that knowledgeable
about it
it's you're just engrossed it's it's
amazing
he's fantastic you don't
so here's a great example i'm not an f1
fan
right i don't follow it senna's my
favorite documentary
i love that documentary it's so good
i don't care about the racing right so
this is why i like revisiting tarantino
films whether you're a fan or not
to sit and just look at the majesty that
he creates
is fascinating he he's
he's just fascinating right and and you
had said something in an interview
that he pays attention to detail and
he'll go i think you use the example of
a pub and listen to people speak
how much research did you put in on
quentin and also
on rick just just you were already a fan
of their films
you knew their work but i mean how much
more were you
were you doing um not a lot actually
and i was very specific not to i watched
their films
i didn't want to know about personal
stuff i didn't want to dig into
i i didn't want to know that stuff um so
again going back to that innocence and
the
the stories to come out as i sat with
people i wanted that to be fresh to me
and what and what resonated
so that if i heard that in the news
somewhere else or read it somewhere
it would have been i feel like deluded
so i was very careful to not
or i thought i should say i fought not
looking at
certain things right because there's
great there's great books um
on quentin and on his style and on his
history
and i i almost did i was like maybe i
should be better informed
but it's somebody else's opinion
of and i just kind of wanted
whoever i was sitting with i wanted
theirs i didn't want another opinion to
to to be in my brain or something to be
said
and i've heard it elsewhere so i dismiss
it right
so i was very careful to not do too much
research
yeah i find that interesting because
it's sometimes very helpful
in getting the best out of someone
because there's a sense of discovery
with it
if you know too much and then again in
the personal life i find that clouds
i mean just being in the world you hear
about quentin tarantino right sure so
there's already enough
there that you almost have to you know
put your muffs on to not hear about him
when a film comes out or what happened
or
people talking about filmmaking ever in
general or daily life actually comes out
uh
so there's definitely there's enough out
there about quinn i i didn't want to
i didn't want to flood more right i have
sins
yeah it's fine absolutely yeah i know
i'm going to eat it all
right but in the moment i agree i think
sometimes knowing
who someone's spouse is or whatever it
clouds the interview
because now you have that in your mind
if you don't know that personal stuff
then now you're just talking about the
work if that's what you're there for
if you're there for something where it's
more personal then it'd be different but
if it's about the work i agree i think
that would be
so a great example actually is with
regard to uma
so there's so much in the news about uma
and
after the car accident oh they've
they've fallen out they hate each other
there's
there's so many different stories about
that relationship
and when the truth came out from uma
it was okay that that that's what the
truth is
right so and actually she came out and
said something out the post
the weinstein stuff i don't have issue
with quentin i
so you know i have issue with the fact
that the footage was
was withheld from me oh right and they
had a
falling out it was a terrible thing that
happened
and life happens right sure but they
have since
come back to each other and they're
they're friends and what have you so
if i did do too much investigating into
into that story there's a lot of
conjecture out there about it and it may
have skewed
how i took what i learned in the process
right also even reading comments i think
can can skew
because sometimes you're not sure where
is this person someone on the inside
is it just some person that's delusional
who actually is close to that person
where they have the correct information
who yeah
there's a lot of voices right right in
the world
today especially with social media and
such that
so then your advice maybe for another
documentarian is
go in but don't don't go in blind of
course but then don't go in maybe
with too much because it's better for
the discovery i think so
i think so with regard to people
right um that's a good point right if
you're
documenting uh
if it's a historical documentary
something like that that's much
different obviously
i'd read everything on that subject
right and then you balance out
everything you've taken
but i think when it comes to people
uh we're not our culture isn't very
respectful of that
so in order to be respectful i think you
need to hear it from
from the person right i don't think the
the research applies necessarily
how did you structure the interview with
samuel l jackson
how did i structure it well we always
started with
when you hear quinn tarantino
what first comes to mind for you what
are the words and the feelings
so he started there and i think he
almost fell off his chair
he's a queen and it was
probably three minutes of
words and feelings that come to mind
with quentin tarantino
um so we started there um how do we
structure it
um you know we we did work for i wish i
could remember the list of questions we
had for him
specifically but we definitely had a
list
um how he met quentin
how that changed as he got to know him
you know how is he different on
because sam uh autism auditioned for
reservoir dogs
so so i did know that right so
how was that first experience
and meeting quinton different from now
as a person as a person
and how is he different as a filmmaker
um
and that really framed the uh the
interview
and a lot happened in that frame so
he was great he was great
once you got the footage back uh did you
you have an editor that was working on
it or did you edit the film
oh no oh okay yeah i had it okay
were you sitting with them and trying to
make sense of
yes this like eight years and so many
voices and yes so um
uh sitting down going through the
footage uh and then you learn
you learn again you see things and hear
things that you
didn't catch while you're sitting live
um you start to see the what's repeated
um about quentin specifically like the
uh
that's where that's where the magic
happens for me is where you start to see
the repetition of who this person really
is
and how and where it overlaps uh and
that was we i think we have
45 plus hours oh of
footage it's like it's really i don't
know to do all this footage like
we got to find somewhere else to go this
this should have been three hours long
to try to like put quinton
into one documentary same like there's
once upon a time in hollywood
yeah see wasn't it or like two and a
half yes
well and he's re-cutting or
yeah re-cutting and putting out an
extended version oh yes
back into theaters because he's quitting
and he can i mean
right now i want to see it no time has
even gone by
nobody does that like he does he's like
i'm going to do this now
because it makes sense right it doesn't
make sense the industry
but it makes sense to quinn and it makes
sense to quentin's viewers
and he knows that right so he changes
how the industry
works i think he's he's brilliant
that's cool i can't wait for it to come
out i want to see it i've already seen
the film twice
in theaters yeah i saw it once with a
packed audience
and it was too much i wanted to see it
that was fun
but i wanted to see it more where i
could let certain scenes sink in
so it was better seeing it where there
was just a few people around and then i
could take it in more
because it was it was so high energy
there were so many people
that was cool that's great energy but
then to really let the story
kind of like sink in and and
you know i think some of it's based on
that time in l.a and then some of it's
sort of
embellished right it's not a total
recount of the
the manson tate you know oh i think just
some of it's
mentioned but it's not like a fool like
historical recount so
i just wanted to see you know and and
plus knowing that there is like so many
opinions about it
you just it's just kind of interesting i
think something becomes more interesting
i want to see it more
when there's either praise or criticism
i mean maybe sometimes even criticism i
think it gets me to want to see
something more
i want to watch it again since
i want to watch it again anyway but
especially after
the conversation about margot robbie's
character not having enough lines
i can't believe that hasn't just gone
away yet but
i already have my opinion on that but
well she was supposed to be enjoying
life
so maybe yeah there wasn't a lot to say
just enjoying it i think it was a great
decision though
and here's a that this is a great
example of
your damned if you do damned if you
don't imagine if he gave her
excessive lines that's true
sharon tate yeah as we know her and
don't
right if he just made her
whatever could you imagine what people
would have to say about that
right right they had things to say about
other characters
right that again that's her being who
she is
and that's where i was bringing it back
to the question of when the artists
work is clouded so much by their
previous work
and who sort of the audience thinks the
artist is
and then there's all these pot shots
about different things that are taken
for him specifically i think that's a
great example of him not
succumbing to that completely if he has
in other aspects maybe
but that decision i think proves
otherwise because he's robust right he's
known for this he's known for
going and elaborating and not
embellishing necessarily but
going big and he's going to push it to
the edge right
but he he left her to live there
right so i thought it was a brilliant
decision
yeah but now maybe i am biased i can't
wait to see the extended version so
what has been your hardest year as a
filmmaker and why
the best for last yeah what's been my
hardest year as a filmmaker
um uh 2017
right yeah and again i have to i have to
revisit with what made
finishing this film difficult sure um it
was it was a very difficult year
fighting um for that film back fighting
for the documentary back
so any advice to other filmmakers who
maybe they're not in the exact same
situation with the same
set of issues but one where like the
film hangs in the balance and they don't
know
what's going to happen um
i i've touched on this with filmmakers a
little bit
when it when it comes down to something
like that
um or even close to
[Music]
a situation where your film is hanging
um
some you have to decide what's too
precious or not
and if if what you've just created
is worth the fight that it needs
to get it back in in this case i learned
enough about quentin
and um what this film was saying
and i felt that it was definitely it
it had a new drive to it
and definitely was something i needed to
fight for
honestly if it was
if it was another director possibly
and something like this happened not as
specific obviously
uh but it might have been
i might have sat and waited because
there was time to wait
right so i think you need to really pull
yourself away from
your passion as a filmmaker and take the
whole thing into consideration
and the life of the film and whether you
need to push right now
or you can sit and and wait
um i hope that answers that
and probably knowing the the um the
level of the interviews that you got too
i mean
filmmakers can be very precious it has
to happen right now it has to do this it
has to do that it has because you feel
that
and sometimes that's true and i think
sometimes
you can stop
that's the best advice i can i think i i
can give because
we will kill ourselves as filmmakers
if we let it go too far you don't have
to
all the time
you